[Music]
foreign
[Music]
which is the acronym for future is
accessible
[Music]
since I work more and more as a
dramaturk I would describe that work
more as
I'm double checking dramaturgies
in terms of is this piece
also great for visually impaired and
blind audience members not just
accessible great
[Music]
I think I've never made a piece that was
specifically only for blind obviously
impaired people
but what I do or achieve are projects
that I accept to collaborate are
projects that have in mind that also In
Their audience
visually impaired and blind people are
we there try to find Solutions of like
how is how is dancing together if it's
not about being visual with each other
and for me it was also then really
interesting to explore dance when you
actually don't need
um
an audio description because the audio
description sometimes
it feels like it's forcing me to see
which I rarely do but then hearing all
the descriptions of the visuals is kind
of I experience the performance plus I
have to hear all the visual stuff that's
happening it's kind of like forcing this
way of perceiving on to me I would
rather having the freedom to explore it
myself
foreign
[Music]
art I noticed it's not accessible I have
to and I had to
fight all the time to have access I had
to become an activist it was not really
by choice even if I don't talk about
disability this is so rare that we see
disabled people in the scene
and just with my presence it's already
activist
foreign
[Music]